We're here in London
and we're going to find out
can people play
for one minute straight?
If they can survive
they get $100
Let's do it!
We've set up the room
full of cheeky little distractions
Let's hope they're good enough
When we say so
The timer will go on
and you have 60 seconds
There might be some...
Surprises!
Ready!
Set!
Go!
60 seconds
Otto, they look quite solid
Maybe if we dim the lights down a bit
Oh no!
Still going strong
They can still see the ball?
16 seconds
Oh no!
Ten seconds left!
Can you do it?
Eight!
OH NO!
It all fell for the guillotine
Was it difficult?
It's like the nerves
We could do that any time
Yeah?
Not when there's 100 quids on like that
60 seconds in the clock
Starting
Three, two, one
Go!
Oh!
You went for your best serve
"I don't care about the 60 seconds"
"As long as I beat him!"
Soon as I turn
he's going to put me in a retirement home
"Alright dad, get out!"
Both of us against each other?
No!
We're not getting each other
We're trying to help each other
Just like a nice...
up and down!
Three, two, one
Go!
Shall we hit them with the lights?
Umm...
You can do it!
Let's hit them with the lights
AAAAA!
That's cheating!
I heard you two go:
"Turn the lights off"
I'm scared!
Go!
Good!
Five seconds in
Nice!
Keep it going!
Still got it!
Oh no!
That's a no?
Yeah!
So all you got to do
is keep the ball in play for 60 seconds
Okay!
And if you can do it
you get £100!
Nice background
Let's put them in space
Yes!
it's going well
Don't mind us
We'll just have a game of our own here
I hope we're not disturbing you too much
Naww!
Otto, this doesn't affect them at all!
We've got to think of something
Woo!
Ten!
OH NO!
They missed it with a swinging racket
No one has completed
the 60 second challenge yet
Maybe our presence is just so
intimidating that people get nervous
These their...
Uuh!
Very nice!
These are our own rackets
Oh okay!
These are nice, bruh!
Go!
Don't mind me
Les, don't pay attention to him bruh
He is not even there!
Six!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
Go!
YEAH!
C'MOON!
Don't forget the money, bruh!
Yeah!
You should play one point
Winner gets the money
Yeah, one point winner gets the money
Absolutely not because he's better than me
One point!
He would take the £100!
One point winner gets the money
Let's go!
Fine!
Sudden death!
C'moon!
I don't believe it!
Well played!
Well done, man!
Give me that money
I'm gonna go!
You had subscribed to Pongfinity, right?
I am subscribed
That’s why I clocked you straight away
That is good!
And I didn't want to say it
There's no way he's in Old Street Bounce
Go and hit subscribe!
You won't regret it
Am I right?
Oh definitely not!
Go!
Noo!
We've been done
by the caution sign!
The wet floor sign
I can't believe it!
And along the video
We'll be having different distractions
So make sure you watch until the end
We'll definitely gonna do really rubbish
Do we just get one go at it?
Just one!
My god!
Go!
You can go as slow as you need
I don't know how to go any slower
Oh!
Ten seconds in!
You can do it
Oh!
It was the pressure
Go!
They're going high tempo
That's a new tactic
Maybe that's the winning tactic
Nice and easy!
But it's looking really solid
Oh, they hit the racket
Oh, but you can...
Ahh!
It never last more than a minute as it is
Stay calm!
I'm calm!
Ready!
Set!
Go!
60 seconds
Keep it...
Oh!
Almost missed it
Chill!
One distraction ball
Oh no!
The one distraction ball this time
Are you famous?
No, no, no
Don't worry!
We're...
Am I going to be on Youtube?
And on the count of three
the timer...
You're looking really nervous
I'm really nervous!
Do you want a glass of water or anything?
Go!
Started at 54 but it...
We'll give them that
You can do it!
Going good!
20 seconds gone!
Keep it going!
35!
Come on!
Just keep it going!
Half way
Shut up!
Come on!
No!
We'll still win the money
Yeah!
Three!
Two!
One!
Oh no!
Can we have the money?
No, but we just won!
It was 2,1...
No, we didn't win
You missed it previously
That was a good game!
Half the price!
Okay!
Let us know in the comments
Do you think they managed the rally?
I hope we do
Come on, guys!
We've been playing for five minutes outside
but in here we're going to do it
for like five seconds, I'm sure!
Make it challenging, please!
Oh, we're going to make it challenging
Don't worry!
Go!
60 seconds started
Otto, what you think?
They are going for the high balls
Yeah, that's a new tactic
Haven't seen that before
Today at least
Because it's not the amounts of shots
It's just the amount of time
Let's give them some
other balls
Oh!
Yeah!
You're 30 seconds in
Seven!
Six!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
That was cool!
Hundred quid
Thank you very much!
Cheers, guys!
Thumbs up, guys!
I know your channel
Really?
Yeah!
I've seen you guys
We've got this, okay?
We've got this!
Hundred quid
Easy money!
Go!
60 seconds has started
Let's slow it down a bit
There we go!
Some intense music
Looking good, guys!
Keep it up!
I know you're about to mess with us
Half a minute already!
You can do it!
You too!
Come on!
15 seconds left!
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
Five!
They are still going!
OH NO!
No!
What we're on?
3 seconds!
Come on!
NO!
The next distraction
dinosaur attack
ROOOAAAAARRRR!!!!!
There might be some
slight distractions
No beef here
No drama!
Are we ready?
No!
Ready!
Set!
Go!
60 seconds has started
They're going strong
ARRGH!
They're unfazed by the dinosaur
Oh my god!
25 seconds left!
Nooooo!
This got me!
This was more scary
than the dinosaur!
You know what?
I should come back with my sister
because we both play competitively
And we could do that
I love your faith in me here
Yeah!
Table tennis gods...
I forsake the minigolf gods
Go!
There's...
Yeah!
Oh no!
I can't believe how quickly I failed that
That was six seconds
That's not good!
I didn't have any expectations to begin with
Wow!
How long do we have for this?
60!
It's never going to happen
How long do we have?
Well, you have one try
But it's not going to happen
I'm never going to do this
Can I get someone else to come in
and take my...
If you find someone else
Yeah!
Go!
One!
Two!
Three!
Now you definitely have it
Oh no!
Three!
Don't mess up the serve
One!
Go!
Also fast tempo
Fast tempo but looking strong
this pair as well
30 seconds
Nice and chill!
The pressure in on
Nothing special, mate!
Can they do it?
You can do it!
Don't hit it too far
Feeling the pressure!
The lights don't help, guys
Just saying!
Five!
Wow!
Four!
Three!
Aaah!
Two!
No!
One second!
Are you joking?
I was about to say:
"Don't worry about the pendulum
it will never hit"
No!
We're going to have to check the replay
because that was on the second
Oh my god!
When did the ball hit the ground
and go out?
Just saying
That's a good point
If it hits the ground...
The ball didn't hit the ground before
I think you got it
Yeah!
Thank guys!
Thank you very much!
Hundred pounds
Thank you guys!
That's really kind
Make sure you hit subscribe
and see you next time
And huge thanks to
Bounce Old Street
for letting us use their amazing venue
I've just got to stand next to
the table and look at
them.